If you didn't ask somebody for money today,
if you didn't prospect, guys, every single one of you,
if you're not on the phone every single day,
Monday through Friday, go ahead, take the weekend off,
I don't care.
I know when I was coming up,
I was working Saturday mornings minimum,
and I have kids and I got other stuff too,
but I was working Saturday mornings doing sales calls.
I was doing something sales related
every single day of the week.
You may not have the ability to ask somebody for money
every single day because you don't have enough deals
in the pipe.
Every single one of you should be on the phone
doing prospecting calls every single day.
But Nick, I don't have a campaign that's generating leads.
Who cares?
Go pick a random city and practice, okay?
Get good at doing it while you're waiting,
or go hook somebody in advance.
Find the area that you wanna go into
and hook somebody while you wait for the leads to come in.
I mean, heaven forbid, okay?
Guys, the work that actually moves the needle
is talking to business owners, doing sales.
That's the work that matters.
How much have you done this week?
My guess is that 99% of you guys haven't done jack shit.
That's the truth.
Well, I watched some training videos.
I watched the live.
I spent an hour looking at due diligence.
Cool, good job.
Go do 100, then outsource it.
Go do 100 due diligence.
Master the process of finding a city and niche.
Go hire someone for pennies in the Philippines
and get that off your plate and focus on sales, okay?
Oh, but I wrote content.
Awesome.
Go write 20,000 words of content
for your first five websites.
Train somebody from the Philippines or Africa or whatever.
Create a process, outsource it.
Spend more time on sales.
You wanna make more money?
Spend more time on sales, okay?
Don't sit there and think that you're doing work
because you're watching videos
or you're listening to fricking Joe Rogan
or you're listening to Jocko Willink
talking about getting in the ice bath.
Do sales.
Call people.